Є загальне відчуття невизначеності та тривоги.
Ми можемо очікувати різкого спаду.
Питання не в тому, чи буде рецесія.
Питання в тому,
наскільки серйозною вона буде.
У нас немає прецеденту.
Ми не знаємо, скільки часу це триватиме.
Рівень спаду залежить від розвитку епідемії.
Єдине, з чим я можу це порівняти -
так це не з фінансовою кризою,
а зі світовою війною.
І справді, схоже, що всі зібралися
й вирушили на війну.
Де всі?! Це божевілля!
Під час звичайної рецесії
економічна активність падає.
Звичайна рецесія не така вже й погана.
Але нині зовсім інша ситуація.
Це крах як попиту, так і пропозиції.
Ми більше не можемо виробляти продукцію,
коронавірус розірвав ланцюжок поставок.
Це означає, що люди втрачають роботу.
Попит також падає, і люди вже не можуть
сплачувати свої іпотечні кредити
та орендну плату.
Економісти люблять зображати рецесії літерами.
"V" означає різкий короткочасний
спад зі стрімким відновленням.
"U" забирає набагато більше часу,
ніж V-подібний спад.
"W" - це подвійна рецесія.
"L" - кепські справи.
Занепад, який довго залишається на дні.
"І" - найгірше.
Це вже вільне падіння.
Ми сподіваємось, що це буде спад
у V-подібній формі.
Ми всі теж. Але, на жаль,
не це стало
результатом опитування головних економістів.
30%думали, що це буде свого роду
V-подібна форма рецесії,
були і 30% тих, хто абсолютно
не впевнені в цьому.
Крім того, ще добрячі 5-10%,
які думали, що це буде L-форма,
тобто що рецесія триватиме дуже довго.
I-подібна рецесія - прямо вниз.
Виробництво зазнає краху,
просто через те, що цьому вірусу
байдужий той факт, що ми - вид,
який має індустрію.
Він просто сприймає нас
як звичайний вид, як селянина.
Пандемія спричинила найшвидший і найглибший
економічний шок в історії.
Центральні банки та уряди кидають
трильйони на пандемію.
Вони кажуть: скільки б не було потрібно.
Але не всі згодні.
Наскільки успішні уряди у стримуванні
економічної кризи через вірус?
У нас була фінансова криза,
яку насправді ще не подолали.
Була криза Єврозони,
яку теж не подолали.
І зараз у нас вірус спричиняє чергову кризу,
і ми чітко бачимо, що наша стратегія
останніх 30 років -
для вирішення усіх проблем в економіці
надавати дешеві гроші та дедалі
більше кредитів - добігає кінця.
Немає точки зору, що існує взаємозв’язок між фіскальною
та грошово-кредитною політикою,
незважаючи на дуже великі суми, про які говорять.
Немає такого взаємозв’язку
на міжнародному рівні,
між різними урядами,
який ми бачили у 2008 році.
Глобальна проблема потребує
глобального підходу.
Але вся ця пандемія стосувалася паніки.
Це не мало бути так.
У нас не було вірусу, який був би
таким заразним
і смертельним з часів іспанського грипу.
Це було у 1918 році під час закінчення
Першої світової війни
і тривало до 1919-20 років.
Тоді в нас не було айфонів,
які вироблялися в 30 окремих країнах.
Це означає, що тоді система мала
дуже малий ланцюжок поставок.
Попри це з ситуацією впоралися дуже погано,
її локалізували на рівні,
який нині неможливий.
Тому ми повинні були організувати
наші виробничі та логістичні системи
так, щоб впоратися з цим.
Натомість ми побудували економіку,
яка надзвичайно взаємозалежна.
Ми нині спираємося на дуже,
дуже крихку мережу
товарних потоків для виробництва продукції.
Крім того, в нас рівень приватного боргу,
який втричі перевищує рівень, який був
наприкінці Першої світової війни.
І це означає, що люди збанкрутують.
Всесвітній економічний форум каже,
що роботодавці теж не готові до цього.
Менш ніж 10% коли-небудь думали про пандемію
як частину своїх поточних сценаріїв ризику.
І менше 50% коли-небудь експериментували
бодай з частиною своїх працівників,
щоб працювати віддалено
Люди вмирають від коронавірусу,
поки ми експериментуємо з карантинами.
Відбуваються масові звільнення.
Я теж не знаю, що зі мною станеться.
Наслідки коронавірусу будуть відчутні
ще десятиліттями.
Це може ще більше розколоти суспільство.
Це може створити ще гостріші нерівності,
вбити клин між багатими і бідними.
Масове зростання кількості безхатченків,
заборгованості, соціальних конфліктів.
Я бачу більшрозгніваний електорат
і набагато більш розчароване суспільство.
також суспільство, яке визнає необхідність
відійти від глобалізації,
повернутися до локального виробництва.
Ми побачимо заходи на макроекономічному рівні,
які раніше не можна було уявити.
Ми побачимо світ з більшим втручанням влади,
більш високими темпами інфляції
і процентними ставками,
а центральні банки фінансуватимуть
уряди більш відкрито.
І це зовсім інший світ, ніж той, який ми мали до коронавірусу.
Ми повинні переглянути всю економічну систему.
Можливо, глобалізація видається нам,
так би мовити, занадто доброю.
Це заклик до пробудження, що технологія
та цифровізація економіки
можуть нам допомогти.
Але ми й дуже вразливі в цьому.
Потрібен значний час, щоб відновитися
після цієї справді дуже
глибокої економічної кризи.
А я повертаюся до самоізоляції.
Схоже, що я буду більше працювати
в домашньому офісі.
І читати набагато більше книжок.
Просто сподіваюся, що ці економісти
не в усьому мають рацію.